in general if there's an unknown
screenwriter what are some of the ways
to get their scripts produced you know
not just one that already has two
considering well I don't think it really
matters that's a great question I don't
think it really matters that much
whether you're known or unknown I mean
at the end of the day a script ism is a
road map a blueprint for this other
medium called film but but we're all
you're all three of us are equal judges
right we're wired pretty much the same
way emotionally if we're moved by tears
or laughter if we're moved by the script
we're interested if the roles intrigued
us if the characters intrigued us
weren't interested that goes is that's
as trooper and unknown so the question
is access right it's only about access
and the way you get a film produced is
it is I think really less about strategy
and more about creative authenticity the
careers that I've seen jump off the
start pad the fastest are the writers
who said I am gonna write what I know
what I care about I'm gonna write a
bizarrely unique story the kind of story
where people go oh my god that's
different I mean they're not mimicking
what's done what they think is
commercial what they think people want
to see they just followed their own
drummer and the careers that I launched
most successfully were people who did
just that they were so different it was
such a unique voice that people went oh
my god no maybe that script didn't get
produced but they got hired for
something else where it was their next
script that got produced but I think the
big thing is is is dare to be different
dare to write the story that actors are
hungry for that producers haven't read
ten times in the last month just be
different be you and whatever that is
and it doesn't have to be I'm not saying
be in the world of nonfiction don't
write your life story but take the DNA
that the heart the guts the feelings and
put it into your characters make it come
alive make it three-dimensional
you